[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces lieux tous nouveaux jdg et rouge
qu'est ce que
c'est ben ouais tu trouves pas quand on
a vraiment un décor en carton
[Musique]
oh
attendez vous êtes qui vous casser ou
chez moi bref oui je déménage et s'est
même pas pour faire semblant en plus du
coup on a remballé toutes les consoles
on a débranché la télé mais heureusement
il nous reste la gameboy on n'a jamais
vraiment abordé le sujet des consoles
portables dans les jt j'ai alors que
pourtant paradoxalement ma toute
première console était une console
portable une langue d'atari et même la
game boy la plus connue d'entre elles
est restée jusqu'en 2008 la console la
plus vendue de tous les temps avant de
se faire dépasser par la ps2 d'ailleurs
quitte à parler des portables on
pourrait remonter encore plus les plus
vieux parmi vous se souviendront même
peut-être des jeux électroniques ou des
game and watch ou là on remonte même au
delà de la technologie des consoles
puisque gamin de wacha c'est juste un
strike déjà dessinée qui s'allume et qui
s'éteint mais c'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui on est là pour parler des
vraies consoles portables et plus
précisément de la première arrivée la
gameboy et je sais qu'on devrait dire le
game boy comme pour le gamecube mais je
vais dire là rien que pour emmerder les
puristes sortie en 89 doté d'une
autonomie de 30 heures de quatre touches
en comptant les boutons start et select
d'un rouleau de scotch ainsi que d'un
pistolet semi automatique 9 mm non mais
non nathalie la télé trop loin lors
la game boy est également doté d'une
molette qui vous permettra de régler de
contraste ainsi vous pouvez choisir de
jouer envoyez à l'écran ou pas
la gameboy dispose également d'un port
link qui vous permettra de jouer avec
des amis à des tas de jeux comme tetris
pokémon et tetris en jeu les 10 et plein
d'autres
le temps a passé depuis quand je jouais
à ce machin
j'ai hâte de savoir à quel jeu en jouant
30 ans
merde la gameboy était beaucoup mis en
avant par les publicités comme la
console pour jouer dehors mais je l' ai
déjà dit dans un autre épisode l'écran
n'était pas rétroéclairé et dehors à
cause des reflets qui voyait rien le
seul moyen de jouer dehors c'était de
jouer à l'ombre et pas genre un peu à
l'ombre ces genres bien à l'ombre
arrête de rester enfermé la trentaine
mais y va jouer dehors
évidemment presque tous les jeux qui ont
vu le jour sur nes ou sur super nes ont
eu droit à leur version gameboy parfois
c'était quasiment la même chose on parle
alors d'adaptation ou de portage
ce matin
et forcément d'accord tu fais un portage
sur game boy c'est compliqué non mais
parce que quand tu passes genre d'un jeu
nerveux de baston sur 16 bits avec une
manette à 6 boutons à un truc avec deux
boutons sur gameboy et
attention jeu frein ceux du combat où
c'est du tai chi l'ha ah oui et c'est
pas un problème d'émulation le jeu
tourne vraiment comme ça à 3 ps puis
même au risque pas d'avoir des problèmes
comment différencie sub zero de scorpion
déjà bas c'est facile scorpions c'est le
jaune et sub zero c'est le bleu
[Musique]
et
puis les portes riz sont
tellement dégueulasse que sub zero on
dirait une mamie russe et fatality sais
pas et il n'y a pas de sens les mecs qui
décolle comme des romain dans astérix
alors bon c'est sûr qu'on pourrait se
dire bon après ça va c'est que le
premier ils vont s'améliorer bâtonnets
mortal kombat 4 sur game boy color c'est
sorti six ans après le premier jeu
combien le voir et c'est aussi le
premier à être sorti en couleurs c'est
dégueulasse
mais vous savez ce que disait ma
grand-mère l'important c'est pas l'écran
titre l'importance et le jeu et le
gameplay ouais ma grand-mère était
incroyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kafka sexe et d'argent on dirait que ça
a été fait par un enfant qui vient de
découvrir speight que vous êtes un
compte en oubliez pas la couleur dans
vos jeux de merlin et non de dieu mais
c'est quoi ces animations deux phrases
et pourquoi notre personnage il réagit
même pas quand je la frappe est là je
pense qu'on peut dire que c'est
dégueulasse prend pas trop de risque et
les fatalities on dirait quelqu'un qui
mange une part de tarte en gros plan est
un film et sa serviette waouh c'était
ultra violent enfin je crois mais bref
on n'est pas là pour parler de mortal
kombat et comme dans cette vidéo on n'a
pas beaucoup de temps et bien je vais
prendre un jeu au hasard dans ce carton
et le tester
non pas celui-là
n'ont pas su la
non
oh mon dieu
oh mon dieu oh c'est comme dans les
films d'horreur c'est une malédiction
c'est un objet beauty qui va me suivre
quoi que je fasse non mais c'est normal
c'est parce que c'est le carton des
joues dragon's lair
oui bon bah quand faut y aller
iweb serre sur game boy
[Musique]
bon bah du coup tu es toi ce jeu est
réalisé par la même équipe qui a fait
l'incroyable chef-d'oeuvre que tout le
monde connaît cependant il ne s'agit pas
d'un portage mais d'une version à part
entière et exclusive à la game boy je
vais d'ailleurs classé mille 52e sur
1068 12e pires jeux de la gameboy
pas à dire les dragons serre c'est
toujours une valeur sûre l'histoire du
jeu se passe donc entre dragon's lair 1
et
d'une part en fait parce qu'après avoir
bien chercher ce jeu de sincères nulle
part dans la timeline de dragon's lair
donc déjà on va jouer pour rien donc
après avoir libéré la princesse daphné
des griffes du dragon de retour chez
elle son convoi fut attaquée daphné se
fait donc kidnappé encore ce coup ci par
le terrible sorcier mordoch qui
recherchent la puissante life stone que
possède daphné pendant juste avant de se
faire enlever daphné réussi in extremis
à briser la pierre en plusieurs
fragments pour libérer daphné des
griffes du sorcier vous devrez donc
retrouver les fragments pour
reconstituer la pierre et là vous vous
dis bon bah c'est le coup de la pierre
magique divise en plusieurs fragments un
genre la triforce le grand classique
héros pour me libérer tu te va retrouver
les trois fragments de la pierre magique
ouais mais non ayrault pour me libérer
tu devra retrouver son traitement de la
pierre magique
niveau gameplay on a donc quelque chose
qui n'a rien à voir avec les autres
versions ici s'agira plutôt d'un genre
de jeu plateforme énigme où vous devrez
dans chaque tableau trouver un moyen de
récupérer chaque petite pièce de
fragments alors et de
1,2
ouah
ouah vauxrot attendait c'est un jeu à
patoune c'est un jeu ea patoune ils ont
pas tous nés dragon serre mais quand est
ce que la folie des hommes bateau le
texte s arrêter
et déjà le premier truc est ce que vous
voyez quelque part le compteur des
fragments à ramasser non est ce que vous
voyez quelque part le compteur des vies
parce que votre compteur de vie à votre
compteur des 194 merde à ramasser sa
fiche uniquement pendant une seconde et
demie lorsque vous mourrez en même temps
je peux comprendre un peu parce que
j'imagine la réaction des joueurs
que j'ai un fragment
et j'irai même plus loin le truc des 194
pièce à ramasser et là si t'as pas lu le
livre et tu le sais pas non parce que
c'est marqué nulle part un livre sur
l'écran titre nikkor le jeu se lance et
vu leur gueule puisque ça ressemble à
des carrés ça pourrait autant être des
bonus qui ne sont pas indispensables
pour avancer et du coup tu peut
littéralement lancé le jeu avancé dans
chaque zone et atteindre le dernier
tableau du jeu sans jamais pouvoir finir
le jeu parce que tu auras rien à
ramasser et que tu auras pas la moindre
idée de ce qu'il faut faire mais aller
pour l'intérêt de cette vidéo on va
considérer qu'on a lu le livre est qu'on
sait ce qu'il faut faire et puis de
toute façon c'est pas savoir ce qu'il
faut faire qui va t'aider à finir le jeu
au niveau des plateformes ce jeune a
aucune logique votre personnage peut
marcher partout mais genre littéralement
partout sur les racines sur les branches
et là je veux dire je marcherai sur le
panneau ça fait déjà absurde mesdames je
marche même pas sur le panneau je marche
sur la petit pot du panneau et encore si
ça serait juste complètement con je dis
pas mais non seulement c'est
complètement con mais en plus c'est un
constant genre quoi tout l'alphabet ça
va mais la lettre n c'est un trou
georges peut marcher sur les cascades
mais je passe à travers les plateformes
quoi je marche sur les nuages
je marche sur les nuages mais qu'est ce
qu'est ce que vous avez voulu faire là
cet ancien présenter quoi ce bordel vous
avez quoi dans le cerveau des bulles non
mais regardez cet écran dites moi d'où
vient le danger sur cet écran
est ce que ces gens retombées de la
plateforme est ce que ces genres les
pics ou la plateforme non le danger
c'est la torche à l'arrière-plan passage
une dédicace au magazine console plus de
l'époque qui notait le jeu 93 sur 100 et
nous disait on salue ce d'un bout à
l'autre de l'aventuré les capacités de
la game boy sens vraiment bien exploiter
la musique est entraînante les
graphismes vraiment splendide la
difficulté du jeu est bien dosée et la
jouabilité excellente
alors en même temps venant de la part de
gens qui faisait une mise en page comme
ça alors justement j'ai mon cul alors
j'ai pas parlé des ennemis mais là aussi
que se passe-t-il genre la grosse tête
de mort me tue pas mais par contre
marché sur le de ce hall 6 et
puis quoi dans dragon's lair sur nes le
simple fait de respirer la lettre des
ennemis suffisent à te tuer mais là il
faut littéralement en servir de plate
forme est là mais vas-y marche sur la
grosse tête de mort et le fantôme ils
sont sympa tu vas voir et d'ailleurs
c'est quoi le délire de ce jeu avec les
montagnes russes tous les trois ou
quatre tables on se tape un passage de
merde on doit ramasser des trucs sur un
chariot il y en a tout le temps s'arrête
pas non mais c'était voulu vous savez
dans le jeu vidéo faut pas rester sur
ses acquis il faut savoir innover c'est
pour ça qu'on est mis en place ce
système très ambitieux de montagnes
russes et de plateformes fondé nuit
alors je suis allé enquêter parce que je
trouvais ça un peu étrange un ces
mouvements d'ennemis en cercle comme ça
et ses passages de fête foraine se
trouve que le jeu tout entier est
heureux pompage sans aucune race d'un
jeu nommé roller coaster sur zx spectrum
jusqu'au moindre détail les sprite ont
juste été remplacé le jeu est
strictement identique pardon je vous ai
coupé vous disiez
au passage c'est peut-être pour cette
raison que ce jeu ne s'appelle pas
dragon clair mais dragon's lair the
legends de garder regardez regardez
attendez attendez
voilà mais on peut zoomer encore plus
voilà bref retour au jeu alors
évidemment il n'y a pas de sauvegarde
mais le boss est capable non plus de
mots de passe et noms parce que le jeu
ne s'arrête jamais le jeu n'est pas
composée de plusieurs niveaux le jeu est
composé deux seule et immense niveau que
tu recommences à chaque fois que tu es
tu à la console
elle c'est un nom alors au passage le
jeu est aussi doté d'un mode deux
joueurs un chacun son tour comme dans
super mario bros comme ça au lieu d'en
récupérer 194 tu dois en récupérer
alors je vais clairement pas me casser
le cul à terminer le jeu en entier je
préférerais bouffer du verre pillé je
vous avoue le jeu est ultra dur et
surtout ses buts et de pièges à cons
genre tu tombe dans un trou ça te ramène
400 tableaux en arrière juste non après
bon attendez je me la pose je vais être
honnête c'est difficile de hurler sur le
jeu parce que bon ben je me souviens de
la version nes et forcément dans mon
esprit je le compare à la version nes et
oui c'est mieux on sait mieux comme
mussolini c'est mieux qu hitler qu on
allait
[Musique]
l'idée de ce jeu ça restera quand même
celle là le bouton pour mettre le jeu en
pause et sur start évidemment mais si
par hasard quand tu veux enlever la
pause tu te trompes de boutons et que tu
appuies sur cnet ce qui peut arriver
quand même vu la proximité de deux
boutons le jeu se
réserve voilà c'est être un gangster il
y avait un dragon non il y avait un air
non g20 ce
métier on va s'arrêter là il ya le
déménageur qui arrive
à quoi là dedans de la merde mais non
pas de la merde c'est mais je programme
[Musique]